♪♪♪♪
-Hello, everybody,
and welcome back
to "Corrections"
for the week of April 19th
For those of you
who do not know,
"Corrections"
is a digital exclusive,
which is a fancy word that means
"not good enough
for television."
[ Laughter ]
This is an ongoing
collaborative effort
between me and the audienc
to get things exactly right.
-[ Coughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I want to start last week.
This is sort of a --
I should note most
of the corrections are based
on things that were said
in previous corrections.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about the fact
that Benjamin Franklin's wife --
although we established,
last week, common-law wife
It's really quite a story.
I got it all off Wikipedia
And, while I'm reading
about Ben Franklin in Wikipedia,
it occurred to me
someone should write a boo
about that guy.
[ Laughter ]
Ben Franklin's wife's name
was Deborah
and I thought that was funny
because that did not seem
like a name
that would be around
in revolutionary times
and then, people pointed out
Deborah was in the Bible.
And then,
I said in another corrections,
"What's next, Candace goin
to be in the Bible?"
And then I found out Candace
was, indeed, in the Bible.
And then, last week, I said,
because someone
pointed out to me
that Candace was
a queen of Ethiopia.
Then I was told Candace
is a title that means "queen."
Yeah, like pharaoh, you know
So pharaoh's not a name.
It just means "king."
So Candace means "queen,"
which is why, probably,
one of the most popular
catchphrases in the Bible is
"Yasss, Candace!"
[ Laughter ]
Did you like that, Amber?
-Yeah, I did like that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I said journey man,
instead of journeyman,
and then, I point outed
that a journey man
would be Steve Perry.
Then, it was pointed out to me
that he's no longer in Journey
He's an ex-Journey man.
So I should've said Neil Schon
Guys, I've been getting
this one wrong
for almost a full month, now
Prime minister of Ireland
has a title.
I first said it was "Tay-sha
[Taoiseach],
corrected, said it last week
"Tea-sock."
I've been told, now,
it is "Tea-shock."
Now, I'm sure
that's not perfect.
I also pointed out, last week,
that we were really upset
to get that wrong
because we have
an Irish poet on staff,
an old man named Seamus,
[ Laughter ]
and I pointed out
that he sort of fell aslee
at the wheel on that,
probably because he was
a little drunk.
And I said that Seamus
often says to us
that he wants a wee taste.
Someone pointed out "wee" is not
what Irish people say.
It's what Scottish people say.
So, we did some digging.
We checked his paper.
It turns out Seamus is Scottish.
[ Laughter ]
He's an old Scottish poem.
Poet, excuse me,
and, obviously,
he's been let go.
[ Laughter ]
Because you don't --
You know, when you're lookin
to hire an Irishman,
you don't want
to hire a Scots man.
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way,
we don't need an Irish poe
because I realize we have a lo
of Irish guests on the show,
who can teach us how
to say these words, like
Sow-rees Ronan.
[Saoirse]
[ Laughter ]
I was told that,
in a monologue this week,
instead of a reverse mortgage,
I said "revorse" mortgage.
I found that hard to believe
I did some digging
and you tell me.
A revorse mortgage.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I heard "reverse."
Let's hear it one more time.
A revorse mortgage.
You know what bothers me i
nailed mortgage.
[ Laughter ]
And there's just never
any focus on that.
[ Laughter ]
I said "homonyms,"
when what I meant to say
were two words were polysemic.
I did not mean to say it.
I didn't even know
that was a thing.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we did --
We said that Jeanine Pirro
had a television show
on Fox News
called "Jeanine Pinot,"
and a lot of people pointed ou
that, in the graphic,
it was a red wine
and that Pinot is a white wine
And a bunch of people
pointed that out
and I would just like
to say to them --
maybe, next time
you're at a restaurant,
call the sommelier over
and ask them about Pinot noir,
you Philistines.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I'm just going
to come clean
that I had to go
to Shoemaker's office toda
and say, "What's something
you would call people
who don't know about wine?
[ Laughter ]
And he said, "Philistine."
So I used it, but I didn't
have it earlier today.
And Philistine,
also from the Bible.
It was Phyllis.
There's a woman in the Bible..
[ Laughter ]
...an Israelite
named Phyllis Stein...
[ Laughter ]
...who just hates --
She was ve--
She was very indifferent
and hostile to the arts.
"Phyllis Stein,"
they would say.
There's a whole section
of it in the Bible.
[ Laughter ]
People are like, "Phyllis,
there's a new
exhibit at the museum."
She's like --
[ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
"What do I need that for?"
And they're like,
"You want some nice wine?"
And she's like, "Wine?
Who am I, the Candace of Sheba?"
[ Laughter ]
And they would always go
to her husband, Irving Stein..
[ Laughter ]
...and say, "Irving,
can you talk to them?
[ Laughing ]
Can you talk to Phyllis for us?"
And he would just go, "Ugh!"
Because he was over it.
So, a Philistine is someon
who is hostile
or indifferent to the arts
And a Irving Stein
is someone who is hostile
or indifferent to a Philistine
[ Laughter ]
[ Sigh ]
So --
We mentioned Pogs,
now, two weeks ago,
and someone said, "Hey,
I'm calling you out, Seth.
You were 31 when Pogs came out
You didn't write that joke,"
and then, last week, I said,
"I didn't. You got me.
John Mulaney wrote that joke
which means, by that math,
John was a 22-year-old
Pog enthusiast."
Then, a bunch of people said
"Hey, man,
you got bad data
from the first correctioner.
Because Pogs were -- mid-'90
was the height of Pogs,"
so I was 22, let's say,
when Pogs became very popular.
Too old for it.
Mulaney was like 10
or 11 years old,
so it is quite possible that h
was a Pog enthusiast then.
I got confused
when I called him
a Pog enthusiast last week
because, when I met him,
when he was like 25, 26,
when he got hired at "SNL,
he was still super into Pogs
[ Laughter ]
You remember.
He wanted to get paid in Pog
and we had to say,
"We'll pay you money
and you can use it
to buy Pogs."
And he was like, "Ugh.
I'd love to
cut out the middleman."
[ Laughter ]
I think it was a tax thing
Do you know what Pog stands for?
Anybody?
Pogs were --
It's a Hawaiian thing
and there was a drink called
passion-fruit orange guava
That's what Pog comes from
Don't look at me like I'm
[bleep] making it up, Shoemaker.
You know what? That's
the hardest part about this,
is how little
you want new information.
[ Laughter ]
You are a Phyllis Stein.
What else do we got?
Oh, somebody said,
when we used --
We used it again tonight.
There's that LMFAO-Lil Jon son
"Shots, shots, shots, shots.
The name of that song,
of course, is
"Midday Revelry."
[ Laughter ]
Somebody said, "Hey, don't pla
'Shots' that many times
without the 'Everybody.'"
That's not a correction.
This is correct.
I'm not taking requests, here.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
That's a different thing.
If you want to correct me,
I'll take it,
but we can't mess around
with this format.
Because nobody thinks
this is a good idea.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
Nobody --
I'm doing it for you.
No one in my life thinks
it's good I'm doing this.
My therapist was like, "Why do
you think you're doing this?
And I'm like, "I don't know.
Why do you think I'm doing it?
And she said,
"It's obvious to me.
This is due to the fact
that your father
was never satisfied
with your work
and you're trying
to prove to him
that you can, in fact,
be perfect."
And I said, "You don't kno
what you're talking about.
And then, I called my dad up
and I said,
"Papa, did you see
'Corrections'?"
[ Laughter ]
And he said,
"I don't watch online content.
And I said,
"It's a digital exclusive!
[ Laughter ]
So we got to take this
seriously.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
Because why else
are we doing it?
And I want to end tonight --
I don't want just, myself,
[ Tearfully ]
to reflect on the week.
I want everybody on my crew.
And I'm going to leave it
to my director,
Alex, in the booth.
When he feels like everyon
who works here --
because this isn't just me
this is top-down.
When he feels like everyon
understands the importance
of getting everything right,
he can cut the feed.